foreign
[Music]
Morocco Mourns Villages wiped out entire
families killed after the strongest
earthquake in that region in a century
the desperate race to find and through
survivors from underneath the rubble as
Canada stands ready to help we're
working with American government with
the Red Cross with the UN agencies or on
the ground in the disaster Zone tonight
plane problems the Prime Minister has a
plan that doesn't work reliably and he
doesn't have a house to live in reliably
the unexpected ending to the prime
minister's India visit so because of
this film you can't go back to Iran
one filmmaker's big risk at Tiff
Canada's fairy tale finish at the FIBA
World Cup in Canada
what it means for the future of Canadian
basketball
[Music]
global national with paranasser
good evening to you and thanks for
joining us it is a Race Against Time in
Morocco where Rescuers are scrambling to
save people trapped under the rubble
following Friday's rare and devastating
6.8 magnitude earthquake and as people
step through the debris often with their
bare hands aftershocks continue to
Rattle the region the scale of the
damage is overwhelming and the hours
ahead are critical there are reports of
entire Villages being wiped out not a
single Survivor and as the first burials
begin the human toll is growing already
more than 2 000 people are known to have
died and that number is expected to soar
more than 2400 people have been injured
rural communities have been the hardest
hit and the hardest to reach because of
the mountainous terrain Crystal
gemancing just arrived in Morocco where
the huge humanitarian response is now
ramping up Crystal what's it like there
right now
far you really don't have to look very
hard to find people sleeping outside
this structure behind me is one that's a
little bit more elaborate right now
there's about a half a dozen people
there but many are just putting up a
tent wherever they can opting to sleep
outside feeling more security and safety
here and it's hard to blame them
considering what they've been through
the past couple of days
it's a scene echoing across this region
Rescuers sift through ruined buildings
desperately searching for any signs of
life here a woman is discovered and
rescued a rare moment of joy and relief
amid so much pain
since the initial magnitude 6.8
earthquake on Friday horrific scenes
have emerged from closer to the
epicenter roughly 75 kilometers
Southwest of Marrakech in the high Atlas
Mountains
a whole family of six died he says may
God have mercy on them scores of
villages just like this one sustained
major damage the vast majority of people
here are Muslim and the dead are buried
without delay the damage may be even
worse higher up in the mountains but a
lot remains uncertain huge Rock Falls
have made some roads virtually
impassable
fortunately in devastated areas Within
Reach eight is beginning to flow in
earthquakes here aren't unknown but this
was the most powerful one to hit the
region in more than 60 years
in Marrakesh people spent another night
on the streets not Taking Chances
indoors their fears Justified after an
After Shock rattled the region raising
tensions for Morocco's already badly
damaged cultural and economic Hub
this mosque collapsed as a local bird
Cellar fortunately it did not cause any
human losses Marrakesh is nearly 1 000
years old and many buildings in the old
Medina a UNESCO world heritage site were
destroyed over 10 million tours visit
Morocco every year there is no easy exit
for the people who call this home damage
is estimated in the billions of dollars
and it will take years to rebuild but
the human toll can't be measured in
dollars one quarter of the people who
call this small village home are now
dead among thousands killed in this
catastrophic earthquake
the government along with local
charities has been here handing out food
and water and just trying to give people
a little bit of support there is a sense
of the community here on the ground
coming together to try to help each
other out but of course there's also the
International Community a number of
countries offered support and we knew we
do know that Spain and the United
Kingdom are now here on the ground with
special search and rescue teams as well
as dogs the Americans have also arrived
they have brought a team to just try to
get a sense of the humanitarian need
that is currently here in Marrakesh and
as you can see the need is fairly
intense people are outside they're
choosing to stay in places like this and
sleep instead of risking another night
in their buildings Farah I'll send it
back to you
crystal gemancing in Morocco thank you
Crystal the UN estimates 300 000 people
have been affected by this disaster but
behind the numbers are countless stories
of grief and loss as Crystal mentioned
families shattered torn apart multiple
Generations lost forever and in towns
and Villages that are accessible
residents are mourning the dead and
they're pleading for more help Redmond
Shannon reports
the typical brick houses of the Atlas
Mountains stood little chance sitting
above the 6.8 magnitude earthquake so
many of those inside these buildings
died or were badly hurt
I lost two of my daughters says this man
may God have mercy on them they were
sleeping on the first floor and the
ceiling fell on them those injured are
carrying mental scars that may never
healed
about 31 people died here says this man
we use all our efforts to rescue people
we did what we could but there were many
we could not help accounts like these
are replicated across the earthquake
zone it's impossible to know how many
people are still alive in the rubble as
the Moroccan Army clears some of the
blocked Mountain routes Aid is slowly
starting to reach remote Villages
an hour south of America
surveys what's left of his house
our dinner plates left as they were when
his family suddenly fled for safety the
house he says no longer safe to live in
no food no water we lost all security
City it was really catastrophic and we
feel very bad in a nearby Town survivors
of all ages cram into simple tents
facing a third night sleeping outside
we told them we are 24 people in one
tenth says this woman they said they
will give us a spare when one becomes
available many are echoing the early
pleas of survivors of February's
earthquake in turkey and Syria calling
on the government and International
Community for assistance
people are suffering and Aid is late
says this man the situation is dire
Moroccans across the country are doing
what they can to help donating money and
blood whatever Eid arrives from inside
and outside the country it's likely not
to be enough as the extent of This
Disaster slowly becomes clear Redmond
Shannon Global News London
foreign affairs minister Melanie Jolie
says about 4 800 Canadians are
registered with the embassy in Morocco
and that 51 Canadians have requested
information in the region but says no
one has requested help and no Canadian
deaths have been reported the embassy
remains open in Rabat and Ottawa is
urging those who have not registered
already to do so and while Canada has
not provided formal Aid yet Jolie says
the government is organizing supports
we're working with the American
government with the Red Cross with the
UN agencies my colleague Ahmed usan the
minister of International Development
the minister of also defense Bill Blair
and I are in close contact to make sure
that Canada stands ready when the
American government will be able to
present their asks as they're assessing
the situation
Shirley says she is in contact with the
Moroccan government and has been
receiving hourly updates
the G20 Summit has wrapped up a prime
minister Justin Trudeau is still in New
Delhi his plane was supposed to take off
early this morning but was grounded
because of technical issues sinisteree
isri reports that's not the first time
this has happened
the prime minister's plane is sitting on
the tarmac in Delhi it was scheduled to
depart Sunday after the G20 Summit
wrapped but it never left the military
discovered a problem as it was preparing
for takeoff this incident is kind of a
sad metaphor for Canada in a couple ways
the Prime Minister has a plane that
doesn't work reliably and he doesn't
have a house to live in reliably 24
Sussex the prime minister's official
residence is uninhabitable a replacement
aircraft was delivered to Ottawa but it
was not ready in time for the G20 since
Trudeau's been in office his plane has
broken down multiple times in 2016 on
his way to Belgium for trade talks and
again in 2019 his backup plane was
grounded it does not shine very well on
the overall image of Canada but it
reflects the choices that this
government has made this government has
made choices that say defense and
anything related to it simply is not
important and therefore we're not going
to spend money on it it's another other
complication for Trudeau on an India
trip his visit in 2018 was problem
plagued but for different reasons five
years later and his relationship with
Indian Prime Minister Narendra Modi is
not improving
this happens to be one where a moment in
time in which relations are perhaps a
little more strained than they've been
in the past the two had a sit down
behind closed doors in New Delhi after a
weekend of stilted handshakes you read
into what you like Modi raised the issue
of what he calls anti-india activities
of extremist elements in Canada while
Trudeau says he brought up foreign
election interference by India in
Canadian democracy diaspora Canadians
make up a huge proportion of our country
and they should be able to express
themselves and make their choices the
problem with the prime minister's plane
is a wrinkle in his week-long trip to
Asia which just got longer but the
Extended Stay comes as no surprise to
those who say the aircraft should have
been replaced years ago Farah Sharia
Israeli in New Delhi thank you to Ria
Alberta's Health Service pushed to the
brink coming up the growing number of E
coli cases in Calgary
in Ukraine a Canadian Aid worker has
been killed in a Russian missile attack
near buckmut Global Affairs Canada is
confirming the death but not the
Canadian man's identity but the road to
relief Aid Group which helps remove
wounded civilians from Frontline areas
says Anthony and Nat a Canadian man died
in a Russian attack on a vehicle driving
toward bakmut Spain's government has
also confirmed one of its citizens was
also killed the group says that vehicle
they were in suffered a direct hit from
Russian shelling on Saturday while
traveling to macmost
[Music]
and hours after those Aid workers were
killed Russia launched an assault on the
Ukrainian Capital Ukraine's Army says
its air defense system destroyed 26 at
the 33 iranian-made drones fired by
Russian forces which targeted Kiev in
the surrounding region at least five
blasts were heard across the capital The
Barrage which lasted about two hours
destroyed several buildings
there are now 190 lab confirmed cases of
E coli linked to an outbreak in Calgary
27 patients are being treated in
hospital outbreaks were declared this
week at several Calgary daycares all
connected by a Central Kitchen Alberta
Health Services is still investigating
the exact source of the outbreak and a
tweet Alberta's Premier Danielle Smith
says she's asked the health Minister and
the children and families minister to do
a full assessment at the outbreak 19
patients also have developed a serious
kidney issue risking it all at Tiff
ahead an iranian-canadian filmmakers
World premiere that comes at a cost
[Music]
next week we'll mark one year since the
death of Masa amini sparked anti-hajjab
protests in Iran even now Brave women
continue to defy Tehran by showing their
hair and this week a film about Iranian
oppression was one of the first to debut
at the Toronto International Film
Festival
foreign
the short film titled meteor explores
the mysterious death of Amin a gay man
in Iran and the close friend of the
Canadian Iranian filmmaker atifake
kodemoreza she believes he died from HIV
AIDS but was scared to get tested
because it would put his family in
danger I sat down with her for an
interview
activate your film opened as one of the
ones that opened Tiff congratulations it
really looks at the issue of homophobia
and the patriarchy what's it like to be
gay in Iran right now uh well you cannot
identify yourself as gay in Iran since I
immigrated to Canada and I saw that wow
it is great that people can love anyone
that they want and then I compare all
these things with my experience with my
friends that I I lost him
and I know how painful was his life I
was like you know what I will tell my
story and it doesn't matter if I cannot
go back to my country anymore
but I have to share this story so
because of this film you can't go back
to Iran no
how does that feel
that's uh I'm a little bit confused I'm
like what did I do I cannot go back
in a part of my life still there I grew
up there
um my family is still there sometimes I
feel like did I do right things and I'm
keep telling myself yes because woman
life freedom
has taught me
you know achieving Freedom cost a price
and we must be willing to pay September
16th marks one year since masamini died
while in the custody of the morality
police the issue isn't getting as much
attention now a year later so what has
really changed you might not see people
protesting in a street but the
revolution has happened in people's
minds many women in Iran they are not
wearing hijab anymore they know that
they might be arrested they know that
they might be killed in the street but
they risk their life because they are
looking for social and Justice some of
my friends they are right now in jail
because they don't wear hijab because
they are making some Arts about this
revolution which is happening in Iran so
it's like it's
ongoing things in Iran Iran is no
stranger to Revolution what will the
country tree now they'll look like
because of this one in 10 20 30 years
you know they cannot stop New Generation
they're different from us I was born in
the middle of War
and I was thinking this government is
doing well and the rest of I mean they
brainwashed us I was like oh this
government is doing well and the other
countries they don't want they do their
work well but gradually when I grow up I
came out like from the school and was
looking around and then internet came
and we had access to like widows and
movies from other countries I was like
what what where's my freedom as a moment
and I feel like I not match with the
definition that this Society is giving
me as a woman that's why I get out even
after I came here I couldn't criticize
Iranian regime because I wanted to go
back
you know they manipulate you even even
when you get out and you think that you
are free you're not because you want to
have this permission to go back to your
country but you think that when I want
to be myself
so that's why I made meteor and I'm like
I'm happy to do it it's a pleasure
speaking with you thank you so much
[Music]
after weeks of criticism in Spain or
that World Cup kiss Scandal Louise
rubialis is stepping down as president
of the Spanish soccer Federation
Ruby Alice has been under Fire since
kissing star player Jenny hermoso on the
lips after winning the Women's World Cup
he claims it was consensual she says it
was not Spanish prosecutors have opened
a sexual assault case on the issue
meaning rubialis could face criminal
charges according to a new sexual
consent law in Spain he could face up to
four years in prison if found guilty
Spanish players had said they would not
take the fields for Spain's national
team until rubialis was removed
and that's global national for this
Sunday night I'm Farah Nasser and
tonight's your Canada is a slice of
History out of Montreal
officials were handing out about 4 000
rivets as free souvenirs from the
dismantled Champlain Bridge the historic
structure spanned the Saint Lawrence
River from Montreal to the city's South
Shore for more than 50 years until it
was replaced by a new bridge in 2019.
very cool piece of History to have until
next time take care of yourselves and
take care of each other have a great
week good night
foreign
[Music]